[Music]
the college basketball season tips off
tonight with all eyes on the marquee
matchup between duke and kentucky right
here in new york city and for the first
time student athletes can make money off
their name image and likeness known as
their nil this is after ncaa rules
changed players are now partnering with
everything from major clothing brands to
local car dealerships some have inked
sponsorship deals worth thousands even
millions of dollars cbs saturday morning
co-host dana jacobson shows us how it's
all working at the university of
kentucky
it's like night and day from when i
first got here for kentucky basketball
junior keon brooks and freshman teammate
taitai washington the new nil policy is
life-changing you can tell me it's none
of my business but how much did each one
of you make in the first month i don't
even know like i'm not gonna lie to you
yeah i couldn't pinpoint an exact amount
but it's been it's been pretty good to
me so far hundreds
thousands
[Music]
dana mind your own business is what that
one is
[Applause]
deals for these student athletes can
range from autograph signings to social
media promotions what's up guys to cameo
where fans pay for personalized video
messages
handling that newfound money just one
new challenge for the student athletes
and that's where kentucky basketball
coach john calipari says the
universities come in we administrators
and coaches have to be educators
and have to be protectors
because you don't want these young
people to get involved with stuff and
they look back like what what just
happened to me it gives you a chance to
talk financial literacy financial
literacy and knowing what your brand is
worth they want you to go do something
for 50 bucks no
your value is what someone is willing to
pay you don't accept that you don't jump
at the first thing you got to step back
and look at this a little bit i want you
to have as much money as possible know
how to save it and that's what we'll
talk about today to help kentucky turn
to influencer a company that supports
student athletes in building a brand an
app helps them grow their social media
presence while staying in compliance
with school rules i think people will
look at it and say oh you brought
influencer here what does kentucky get
out of that by having influencer
we basically are protecting ourselves
and protecting the students
against themselves doing something they
don't need to do but it's not just
athletes from the big revenue generating
sports that can benefit
hurdler russell is a senior on the track
team she's capitalized on her large
social media following 150 000 on
instagram and more than 400 000 on tick
tock i never planned this i never
planned for this to happen social media
which is something that i love to do
what is the brand that you've created
for yourself that you think some of
these businesses are attracted to i
don't really think who i am like and i
think it's pretty obvious i can tell
already actually yeah i am who i am and
i think that like the brands love that
brands like clothing companies third
love and champ sports who partnered with
russell a lot of people did think it
would be the football players the
basketball players but it's good to know
that i'm an african-american female that
can step up and you know represent these
brands represent myself and who messiah
is on and off the track
and while building a brand is a
full-time job on top of school and a
sport the students say they are ready
for it what do you say to people that
doubt that you can do all of this you
just got to keep your priorities
straight you're not going to be able to
make money or
be famous on social media if you're not
going out on the court and producing or
if you're not eligible because you're
not getting your stuff done a
professional approach by those the ncaa
maintains are amateur athletes for cbs
mornings dana jacobson lexington
kentucky
go messiah russell i already like her i
like her i'm all for it i think this is
fair and square yeah i would like to say
it's about time yeah i agree because at
first nate i was mixed about i thought
is it going to ruin the purity of the
game but now i really do understand it
and get it i love how the guys didn't
want to tell dana what the figures yeah
i am curious about what is a figure
aren't you oh i would say hundreds of
thousands of thousands sure almost
millions and anybody who's hesitant that
might be washington saying well what
about the purity of the game these guys
are amateurs just look at how much these
universities are making
these athletes you'll change your mind
that's what made me switch too yup no
doubt about